The Conjuring franchise ranked by box
office grows number seven The Conjuring
the devil made me do it so this one made
65 million dollars and it did also
release on HBO Max at the same time this
was during covet it's hard to say how
that might have factored into the
Numbers number six Annabelle comes home
making 74 million dollars just seeing
that this has got to be the most
underrated Conjuring film number five
Annabelle making 84 million dollars
remember this came right off of the
heels of the original Conjuring there
was still a lot of hype around what was
going on with this doll number five
Annabelle creation making 102 million
dollars this one actually surpassed the
original Annabelle and all those
annabels are together in a cluster on
the list number three The Conjuring 2
making 102 million four hundred seventy
thousand dollars if you guys are
familiar with my Conjuring content you
know this is my favorite Conjuring film
number two is the nun making 117 million
dollars like the original Annabelle this
character was introduced in a Mainline
Conjuring film and there was a lot of
hype around her getting her own movie
and number one making 137 million
dollars The Conjuring the one that
started it all let me know in the
comments your favorite Conjuring movie